okay good morning welcome to the second
day of resurrection interactive learning
workshop today first off is interactive
clustering by Raja Awasthi from Rutgers
University thanks so this is the stock
is based on a series of works some of
them are joined with roses are they and
the others are joined with Lena Balkan
and Constantine go Watsky so the goal of
this work is to what we were trying to
understand was what happens if
interaction is brought into picture for
tasks that are traditionally
unsupervised ok and a typical example
that you're going to look at in this
talk is is clustering okay so if you
look at most of the theoretical work on
interactive learning a lot of it has
focused on supervised learning so you
know you want to learn a function from
some training data and the question is
how do you get labels for examples and
then there are various models on how do
you get labels for these examples so the
so there's a traditional pack learning
model which is sort of the more passive
learning model you just you just get a
bunch of label data and then you want to
learn something from it and then there
are models like active learning where
the algorithm can adaptively query for
the labels of a given example and
hopefully that will reduce the number of
labels that need to be queried and then
there are many other models that have
been looked at like membership queries
equivalence queries and so on what we
want to understand is what happens if
interaction is used for an unsupervised
learning problem okay so typically an
unsupervised learning problem we don't
think of interaction so we think of your
just given a data set let's say you want
to cluster it into K pieces or you're
given some documents you want to fit an
Lda model to figure out topic
memberships and so on and what we are
interested in is can interaction be
useful for any of these tasks okay so so
let me begin by just defining the
problem so what is clustering you are
given n objects these could be documents
or images and so on and you want to
partition them into K disjoint clusters
okay so that's that's the task of
clustering and what is our goal we want
to be able to design algorithms and we
want to be able to show that these
algorithms are good there they are
probably good they return an optimal
solution or a near optimal solution okay
and in order to do this
need to make some assumptions on what
kind of instance we are looking at so
the classical approach to cluster is is
you can formulate it by an objective
function so you can you can look at an
objective function such as let's say
k-means this K means clustering okay so
you can say that I want to find K
centers these centers will be
representatives for the clusters and I
want to minimize the distance of every
point from its slow the center okay and
so you can say that I want to find a
clustering that minimizes this objective
and I'm going to call that as the right
clustering or the right answer that I am
interested in now now this is good if if
this objective reflects what you really
want okay so this is this is a fair
approach if it is indeed the case that
minimizing this objective function will
lead to the ground truth clustering that
you are interested in but if that is not
the case then then it's not clear why
one should follow this approach okay
another approach is you can make a
generative model assumption on your data
so you can assume that your data is
coming from lesser mixture of gaussians
or your data is generated from a
stochastic block model and so on and
under this generative assumptions you
can try to design algorithms that work
really well and indeed there is a lot of
theoretical work in this direction so
you can design optimal algorithm since
in some cases you can really design
algorithms at work till the right
constants which is great except that
these results are not very robust to the
modeling assumption okay so if you're
modeling assumption is incorrect if data
is not really generated from a mixture
of gaussians or stochastic block models
then it's not really clear what you can
what you can see in these settings okay
so what are both these approaches trying
to do both these approaches are somehow
trying to remove ambiguity from the
problem okay so the problem is ambiguous
as stated because I told you that you
have endpoints you want to partition
them into K clusters now there are many
different partitions which one do you
want to compute and both of these
approaches are somehow trying to remove
the ambiguity in the problem and so what
we are going to look at is can we remove
the ambiguity in the problem by having a
human in the loop okay suppose there is
a human or a teacher in the process who
can guide us in figuring out what the
what the right clustering we should be
looking for okay
and in some cases this really becomes
necessary to interact with the user a
classical example here is personalized
recommendations okay so if I'm trying to
cluster news articles or snapchat videos
try to curate them to suit given
person's taste then it really becomes
necessary for me to interact with this
person to figure out what they like and
what they don't like without that there
is no way for me to a priority define
what the optimal clustering should be
okay so in some cases it really becomes
necessary to interact okay so that's
going to be the bowl of the talk can we
remove ambiguity by having interaction
in the process okay and in general it
leads to a very interesting theoretical
question which is is interaction useful
for unsupervised learning not just
clustering but other unsupervised
learning tasks as well okay so there
have been approaches to include
interaction in in clustering scenarios
and so let me mention two of them so one
is what is not as constrained k beans or
comedian clustering so here the idea is
you solve the standard k-means objective
but then there are some constraints that
you have gathered somehow by interacting
with the user so your user told you that
these pair of items can never go
together or these pair of items must
always go together so you are not
necessarily so you are you are not just
computing the optimal k-means objective
you are computing the optimal caving
subjective under some constraints okay
and these constraints you got by
interacting with the user and there is
another set of work which is looking at
pairwise queries so you can create the
user for a given pair of points and you
can ask whether do they belong to the
same cluster or do they belong to
different clusters okay yeah
where you have some labels right right
so this this approaches this approach is
very similar to semi-supervised learning
so you sort of minimizing an objective
but you have some constraints we are
trying to do constrained minimization
which is what happens in semi-supervised
learning as well okay so what I'm going
to talk about is a different model and
here what we are going to be interested
in is what can we do with minimal
feedback so we are not going to be
interested in feedback at the level of
pair of points okay what if the feedback
is sort of more course than then giving
feedback on pair of points okay so we
are going to be interested in
understanding can we do something with
minimal feedback is our model noise
robust can it handle a lot of noise and
in the end I'm going to briefly talk
about is it is it actually useful just
studying this theoretical model lead to
lead to useful algorithms okay so I'm
going to first define the bare-bones
model and then we are going to slowly
see how we can sort of make it a bit
more practical and mid board nice robust
okay so their bones model was proposed
in 2008 by Vulcan and Blum it's it's a
very neat model and it was inspired by
the equivalence query model for learning
for classification settings okay so if
you are not familiar with the
equivalence query model the model is
like this so you have an algorithm and
then there is a teacher and the
algorithm is interested in learning a
function so that what the algorithm does
is it proposes a function to the teacher
the algorithm says I think this is the
right function H 1 is the right function
and what the teacher does is teacher
responds with a counterexample ok so the
teacher gives an example X said that H 1
of X does not equal H star of X ok so H
star is the right classification for the
example and so teacher says no this is a
counterexample you don't have the right
function ok so the algorithm goes back
and it proposes a different function H 2
and the teacher then gives another
counter example and this process goes on
for a while in the end the algorithm
will propose H star which is the right
function and the teacher will accept
yeah so here we are drink of error
festering here right yes this is the
perfect setting right now so we are
assuming that error of H star is 0 and
when the algorithm proposes H star it
will be accepted okay so we are going to
take the similar setting and use it in a
clustering scenario okay exactly the
same setting so in a clustering scenario
what's going to happen is the algorithm
will propose a clustering to the user so
algorithm partitions the data into let's
say K clusters c1 c2 up to ck okay and
it's going to get some feedback from the
users some feedback about the quality of
the clustering I'm going to get into a
second what this feedback would be but
it gets some feedback on whether this is
the right clustering or not okay and
this will be kind of course feedback it
it will not be very detailed and the
algorithm is going to use this feedback
and then propose another clustering to
the user will again get some feedback
this process will go on and in the end
the algorithm will propose the right
clustering let's call it c1 star C to
start up to seek a star and this
clustering will be accepted by the
teacher okay and the goal would be to
figure out to design algorithms that can
figure out the right clustering by using
very few rounds of interaction okay so
we don't want this process to keep go on
for a while so to make this model more
precise I have to tell you what the
right feedback is going to be and it's
sort of there are two competing goals
here one is that it should be easy to
provide from the teachers point of view
and it should also be informative enough
it should it should let the algorithm
make progress and so the two kinds of
feedback that I'm going to look at our
split and merge feedback okay so let me
define what what this beam so if the
algorithm yeah is their assumption that
there's a unique correct clustering that
the teacher has in mind or that the
teacher will be satisfied with a
clustering that's good for reasonable
right so the assumption in this model is
that there is there is a unique
clustering that the teacher has in mind
and so it seemed exactly similar to
equivalent square e models there is a
unique clustering and if the algorithm
proposes that clustering the process
ends okay
so once the kind of feedback the teacher
is allowed to give so if the algorithm
proposes let's say clustering c12 ck the
teacher can point to a cluster and say
split see I okay what is the semantics
of split see is split see I teachers
allowed to say a split CI if CI contains
points from two or more clusters in the
ground truth okay or in other words if
CI is an impure cluster yeah so just
like you to provide the justification
was split no so in this model the
teacher does not necessarily have to say
why he is asking the split query the
teach I can just say or this cluster
doesn't look right the question is like
why not right because it's natural for
human teachers to say I know these two
points are not right so so so that's a
good that's a good point so sort of this
model is sort of more interested in
looking at what can happen with more
coarse grained feedback so so saying
that this cluster doesn't look right is
the kind of feedback that's very easy to
provide provide from a human humans
point of view you all right so if the
human is willing to provide more
feedback the human can say this is not
right because of because of these
reasons then then one can utilize them
further but but for now we're just going
to assume that the teacher says split CI
and that just means that this cluster is
in pure okay Yeah Yeah right now case
fixed but the algorithm does not
necessarily know it the teacher knows
what K is what the right clustering is
the algorithm does not okay
so the other kind of feedback that the
teacher is allowed to give is is a merge
feedback so if the algorithm proposes
the clustering see where to seek a
teacher can say Marge CI and CJ if CI
and CJ are subsets of the same cluster
in the ground truth okay or in other
words if the algorithm is over clustered
a given cluster if it has computer
really really fine grained clustering
then the teacher can say oh these two
clusters look very similar why don't you
wash them okay so these are the two
kinds of feedback that the teacher is
allowed to give yeah it's ready like do
the points out features or is there like
a metric over the point system all right
so I'll come to that in a second so
right now in this abstract model the
points could be could be anything but
but in order to get interesting results
we will have to make assumptions on what
the points are so so on so what kind of
clustering interaction that has been
studied is where people look at these
must link and cannot win constraints
right these two points have to be
together is so those would automatically
generate constraints of this form right
so whenever the user says must link then
that is emerge right so in in one case
you are correct so then when I user says
cannot link you can you can take that as
a split request so if the user says
cannot link on a given points in a given
cluster you can take that as a split
request but a user says link two points
that might not necessarily mean that you
want to merge those two clusters okay so
so he might just want you to merge these
two points okay so so so there are
similarities but it's not it's not
implied by this one
okay so this is a typical process will
go on like this let's say you have this
image that you want to you want to
segment so maybe the algorithm will
propose this kind of the clustering and
then the teacher will say split split
this cluster then we Olga rhythm goes
ahead and split it like this then the
teacher can say well merge these two
clusters and so on eventually the goal
is that hope is that in a few rounds the
algorithm can figure out the right
segmentation of this image for the right
classroom ok ok so as I said before the
goal is to design an efficient algorithm
that reaches the ground truth in a small
number of rounds ok in this model ok so
here are some easy observation some very
easy observations so this is a trivial
algorithms if i give you n points you
can always cluster them using n minus k
queries or n minus k rounds your
feedback ok what do you do you just
start with each point in its own cluster
you just define each point in its own
cluster and so now you are only going to
get a merge feedback you will not get a
split feedback you'll only get a merge
feedback and whenever you get a much
feedback you just merge those two points
you know that they belong to the same
cluster you just merge them ok and
continue let's sort of the trivial
algorithm just start with every point in
its own cluster and you get a you get a
march query you merge these two points
then you get another much query you
watch these two points and so on so this
is kind of like the teacher sort of just
telling you what the right clustering is
the teacher is just stepwise guiding you
what the right what the right clustering
should be ok so this is not very
interesting unfortunately without
further assumptions this is the best you
can do at this model ok so there are
really pathetic cases where you will be
forced to make these these many these
many rounds of interaction okay but what
if you have some additional assumptions
on these clusters what if these clusters
are nice 10 12 can well do something
better ok and I'm going to look at sort
of two notions of what niceness means
one would be inspired from sort of more
pack learning kind of settings so so
here we are going to assume that there
is a ground truth clustering see one
star up to seek a star and the
membership in each cluster see I can be
decided by a boolean function fi ok so
there is a boolean function and I can
input a point and the function
can tell me whether this point belongs
to the cluster or not okay so a good
example of it is linear separators or
rectangles or geometrical sort of
clusters so for instance in this
scenario each each points membership is
is is decided by whether it falls in a
given rectangle or not ok so the class
of functions here would be rectangles ok
and you want to figure out whether a
point lies in the cluster c1 or c2 you
can figure it out by evaluating it on
the on the corresponding function ok so
what can you show here so here here's a
here's a sort of a theorem you can show
so suppose the membership in cluster I
can be decided by a boolean function fi
and suppose these functions belong to a
class H of VC dimension D then you can
cluster using KD login grounds ok sort
of linear and then we go to logarithmic
in n ok so you can you can cluster this
this data set using KD log and many
queries ok so let me sort of just
briefly go over what the algorithm here
would look like so the algorithm will be
very similar to the version space kind
of algorithms that are used in active
learning ok so we're going to maintain a
version space so in this case the
version space will be all valid
clusterings that that that that the
algorithm might output ok and then we
are going to choose one of these
clusterings from this version space
present it to the teacher and then after
getting a feedback we will delete all
the clusterings that are inconsistent
with the feedback ok so this is exactly
what happens in active learning kind of
scenarios you query for an example and
then you delete every function that that
does not agree with the level of the
exam yeah so in this setup does it does
their end up being some sort of almost
reduction to think about just k binary
classification problems one for each
function fi under maybe something more
similar to the accordance query model or
is there no such connection so there is
no reduction because the kind of
feedback that we are looking at is is
sort of very coarse so that
my question you cannot sort of synthetic
you cannot synthesize there i think i
think what Jerry was pointing out if the
if the feedback was more involved if I
was able to get more fine-grain feedback
then I would be able to convert it to a
sort of a bore classification kind of
sorry but we don't we are not interested
in that regime we are interested in
understanding what can be done with sort
of more course feedback ok so so we are
going to sort of cleverly choose a
clustering and present it to the teacher
and then on feedback will delete every
clustering that's inconsistent from the
feedback and this process will go on for
a while so now I need to tell you what
this which clustering from my current
version space I choose to present to the
teacher ok and the clustering is going
to be the following so you look at your
data and you find the maximal set of
points such that more than half of the
clusterings in your version space
cluster these points together ok so find
a maximal set of points such that more
than half of the clusterings think that
this set of points are pure they go in
the same cluster and once you find such
a set output it as a single cluster
output has a cluster and then repeat on
the remaining points repeat the same
process on the remaining points until I
all the points are clustered and present
that clustering to a user order to the
teacher ok so for instance maybe you're
the first settle output was see one
because see one was the set of points a
maximal set of points such that more
than half of the clustering say yes
these points should go together ok then
maybe I put c2 c3 c4 and so on ok so
that yeah so first you don't have any
problem with innumerable Valley
clustering right so this is an
inefficient algorithm in general so it
will work for any concept class search
also is very inefficient right so it
works for every function class but
toward to make it efficient so you can
get efficient versions of it for for
special cases like rectangles and linear
separators and so on but in general it
will be an efficient algorithm exactly
as in active learning where a general if
you don't have any RM Oracle then then
you sort of have to enumerate the
functions yeah
you don't move into a classroom or you
might you might that's a good point so
so the algorithm does not know k right
so the algorithm can generate whatever
at once so so it's soda yeah so it's
possible that algorithm ends up
generating many more clusters okay so
now what's the claim so the claim is
that after every request after every
feedback half of the version space will
be pruned out okay that's that's
settling ok so now why why is that true
suppose you get a split request well
then it's easy to see so if you get a
split request on this cluster well this
cluster was formed because more than
half of the clusterings said that all
these points go together right so all of
those clusterings we can get rid of so
we got rid of half of the version space
ok now suppose you get a merge request
suppose you get a merge request on CI
and CJ let's say you get merge on c1 c2
now you can get rid of all the
clusterings that do not put these
clusters together ok and that should be
more than half because if that was not
more than half then this wouldn't have
been a maximal set of points that you
output more than half of the clustering
said that these two go together then you
should have output a larger set where
you were in the first step ok so in both
the steps sort of you just delete
clusterings that are inconsistent with
the with the feedback and you get rid of
half of the version space ok and so from
that it's it's sort of easy to see that
you will get KD login quakes ok so
you're pruning the Virgin space by by
half at each step so number of rounds is
going to be Cady times Logan ok any
questions
okay good yeah so the example you showed
it wasn't you had an image and then the
clusters on the segmentation so I just
have probably many settings in which you
can't actually show the whole clustering
well that's right look it afraid and so
presumably just do the same thing with
web them right right right right right
so so in the paper we have some
scenarios of this sort of inductive
setting where instead of showing the
entire clustering to a user you can show
random subsets of each cluster which is
what which is sort of a more practical
practical way to solve the problem you
ensure random subsets of the of each
cluster and and things will still go
through so you don't sort of have to
show the entire transferring to you but
somehow shouldn't it be better to show
things near the boundary then from the
core well I mean what is the boundary
it's unclear what the boundaries yes I
know but just thinking about sort of the
again the specific type of example that
you were showing with the image Friday
that's right algorithmically if you are
showing a random set you you don't want
a uniformly at random so you want to
show question okay so this is sort of
one style of results that you can show
in this model the other style of results
you can show is if you assume that let's
say maybe maybe there is no sort of easy
way to describe a boolean function that
tells you the membership in a given
cluster but maybe over all your ground
truth clustering is stable in some sense
okay it's sort of a nice separated
clustering and one notion that we look
at is what is known as average stability
so this means that on average every
point prefers its own cluster or the
other clusters okay so for instance if
you have two clusters CI and CJ here if
you look at any two subsets of these
clusters and a prime average stability
says that a prefers its own cluster so
if you look at the average distance of a
to the rest of the points in its own
cluster
that's going to be smaller than the
average distance of a to a prime okay
that's what average stability says yeah
so mathematically this like this for
every i not equal to j look at any two
subsets a a prime then the average
distance of so this is similarity here
so average similarity of a with CI star
minus a is larger than the average
similarity of a na prime okay so this is
a different style of assumption so
there's not necessarily a boolean
function that defines here that defines
your clustering but but overall the
clustering is nice it's structured in
some sense and hear what you guys show
is that if this clustering is stable if
you're if you are trying to find a
stable trusting you can do it in k
queries okay k rounds of interaction are
enough to find such a clustering and
let's see what's going to be the
algorithm here so the algorithm will be
the following what you first do is
compute a tree which is known as the
average linkage tree okay so this is
just computing minimum spanning tree
using average distance okay so you want
to compute a minimum spanning tree over
the points for use average distance as
as the measure okay so it will work like
this so say at the bottom you have the
set of all points and then you merge the
minimum of these two so maybe the video
of these two is is this cluster so you
form this this as one internal load and
then maybe you form this cluster perform
this cluster now amongst these three you
look at the ones that have the minimum
average distance and you merge them to
form a higher level node okay so where
you form this node and this node and so
on okay so this is known as the average
linkage tree over the data set okay so
the first step in the algorithm is going
to be to compute this tree ok now the
algorithm will do something something
quite trivial we'll just present the
root node of the tree as a cluster okay
so the algorithm will just look at the
root node of the tree which contains all
the points it will say this is the
cluster okay so now the teacher has no
option teacher has to issue a split
request if the teacher is not happy
teacher has to issue a split request and
so what does the algorithm do on a split
request it just goes to to the two
children of the other node okay so if
you fight if the teacher says split when
it goes here it says okay so now these
are the two clusters okay and now if it
gets split again then it goes further
down it just goes your two children of
the node and says these are little
crystals okay so that's the algorithm so
on every split request it will just go
down the go down the tree okay so
replace the internal node with its two
children
now why does this work this works
because of the following property that
you can show if your instance satisfies
average stability then the target
clustering the ground truth clustering c
star is going to be laminar with respect
to this tree which means that every
cluster in c star will be present
somewhere industry as an intolerant node
okay so every cluster of c star is
present in the street somewhere as an
internal node okay so in other words if
you start from the top of the tree the
teacher will never issue a merge request
the teacher can only issue split
requests we just go down the tree there
you get another split request you go
down the tree at some point of time you
will hit these internal nodes that
correspond to c star and then the
teacher cannot issue any other requests
on on those thoughts so you're sort of
just navigating down to tree to figure
out what the right clustering is ok any
questions it will not be actually on the
branch you request the spirit on the on
the right but your ass or my left it's
it's a partitioning right so so so so if
there's some points here are some points
here there has to be some portion of C
star that's that's here as well so all
of these points are partitioned into
into K clusters so some of some clusters
of C star will go on the left branch
some clusters of C star will go on the
right branch but a cluster will never be
split so this average linkage tree has
the property that every true cluster
will go together until it becomes a
internal node ok yeah true that if you
allow a teacher to give you an integer K
that's the same thing that you should
can just give you the number K and you
can do the same job no because there
could be a good question so that's not
true because there could be multiple
sort of navigations of this tree that
satisfy average stability
yeah so it's it's just knowing k is not
enough
okay so these are sort of this kind of
results are nice but they don't really
lead to very practical algorithms okay
so what are some of the limitations of
these results well one thing is that
they don't account for noises in the
responses okay so so far we are assuming
that when the users or the teacher says
split it's really an impure cluster when
the teacher says barge it's really it's
really a pure cluster but as sanjoy was
mentioning maybe the user sees a few
examples in both the clusters that
really should go together and the
teacher says well why don't you go and
merge these clusters okay so there is
there is naturally going to be some
noise in the responses that we need to
account for and so another issue is that
these algorithms they really rely on the
fact that the algorithm has the choice
to show any arbitrary clustering to the
user so every time it gets a feedback it
can make arbitrary changes to the
clustering and present of fresh
clustering to leave or it can start with
very unnatural clusterings like in the
previous example very short all the
points as a single cluster you just
started with with that and that's not
very desirable in many cities settings
in particular if you are looking for a
better user experience you sort of don't
want to present drastically different
clusterings from from from day 1 to day
2 okay sort of want to present make
changes to your crush drinks in a smooth
fashion arbitrarily keep changing
clusterings okay so here is one attempt
that that we have in sort of making
making this basic model a bit more
practical so you're going to model noise
as follows so we're going to assume
still assume that splits are perfect so
the user says split then it really means
that the cluster is impure but if the
users or the teacher says that you
should merge the two clusters then then
exactly what Sanjay was saying might be
true so the user asks you to merge CI
and CJ then we are going to assume that
a1 minus ETA fraction of both the
clusters belongs longs together but the
Nita fraction is noise okay so ETA is
the noise rate and experimentally this
turns out to be the case so people are
usually much better at issuing split
requests than maje requests so merge
requests and we tend to be quite more
not noisy than then spill
again so that's what we're gonna do we
are going to model we're going to assume
that the merges are noisy from now on
okay so that is the noise rate is ETA
and they also enforce locality in our
algorithm so so what does locality means
so the first constraint is going to be
that the algorithm cannot choose the
initial clustering okay so the algorithm
cannot just start with any arbitrary
clustering you want the algorithm will
be given a clustering the algorithm has
to start from that okay so this is this
is useful for scenarios where you
already have a system in place let's say
you already have a system in place and
you have let's say clustering on some
documents that you are using to make
some predictions okay so you already
have a clustering that's quite good it's
not perfect and it's already in use in a
further down the pipeline to help you
make some predictions and now you want
to add this interactive learning
component to to sort of improve this
clustering okay so this would be a kind
of scenario where the algorithm does not
really have a choice to start from an
arbitrary clustering the algorithm has
to start from this clustering and sort
of make changes smoothly because you are
using this clustering down the pipeline
to make make predictions okay so the
very are gonna enforce locality is that
the algorithm cannot choose the initial
clustering and the algorithm can only
modify clusters that were involved in
the feedback okay so if i gave you
feedback on a given cluster you can only
modify that cluster you cannot touch
other parts of the clustering you cannot
sort of rearrange points arbitrarily and
try to compute a clever clustering that
will help you prove in a lot of the
space
and so of course the measure of progress
here is going to be on how far you start
how far your initial clustering is from
from the ground truth okay so you start
really far then then you might need more
rounds of interaction if you start close
enough you might eat less rounds and so
here is a here is a theorem that you can
prove if cease are stable against the
notion of stability is again average
stability they're different before she
says stable you can find it using
epsilon 0 plus K over 1 minus ETA log
and queries okay so k was with no noise
and with arbitrary sort of choice of
initialization we were able to get it in
cake ways now if you enforce this
locality constraint and you cannot
choose the initial clustering the bound
sort of becomes bad but it's not that
bad so it's epsilon 0 plus K times log N
and epsilon 0 here is the error of the
initial clustering because epsilon 0 is
how far how far from the ground truth we
are starting from under an appropriate
notion of error yeah that's that's a
theorem you can prove and the algorithm
is actually quite similar to what we did
before so we as before we are going to
construct an average linkage tree and
again on a split request you will just
go down the children in the tree but the
merge requests are going to be a little
little complicated so on a merge request
you are going to do a depth-first search
to find a node which has enough points
from CI and CJ and then well you know
that some portion of the because the
user has issued a merge request some
portion of these clusters is is kind of
pure some portion of these clusters goes
together and what the algorithm will do
is will try to sort of carefully carve
out this portion so that it can make
progress
good so epsilon here would be at most K
squared is the worst case it will be K
squared so epsilon zero is sort of the
number of so for every cluster you look
at how many clusters it's been
partitioned into in the initial Pacific
so it's not a point wise error so you
look at every cluster every optimal
cluster you get how much it has been
over clustered and how much it has been
under clustered okay so for every
cluster you will incur maybe a cost of K
so overall it's k squared okay yeah
where is the initial clustering come in
you you construct an average linkage
street where the leaves are the initial
customer no no no no no norton or leaves
our initial cluster you construct the
average linkage to be on the whole data
set okay so where does the initial
Buster England oh so so you have it you
have a tree right but but you cannot
navigate from the top of the tree
because the request is going to be on on
one of the clusters in the initial
clustering right so let's say that I see
one is a cluster in the initial plus
drink so if you get a split on c1 you go
and find where c1 is in the in the tree
so you go and find a node where a lot of
c1 is sitting and then that's the node
where you sort of that that's a note
that you process ok so the tree is still
a global tree but you cannot navigate
from the top for the tree someone else
had a question it was the same question
ok just that is the initial clustering
layer to the tree are you using only the
tree to make incremental changes to the
xmas tree yes using it only today
this plate is not sort of as direct
anymore right because CC if the the
cluster you receive the spirit request
on does not need to be an actual node
right exactly it does not need to be an
actual note so what you need to do is
you need to find a node which contains
find a deepest node which contains all
of it and sort of go to X children um
yes on that matter because the actual
cluster C 1 is not necessarily in your
tree you find the other sort of the
smallest should note that can has it
right when you split is here I guarantee
that you actually split the users that's
right so so remember that the optimal
clustering is still stable right so so
the tree that we construct the optimal
clustering is still some we are present
in the tree nicely it's just that we
cannot stop a start from the world from
the top of the tree and navigate but
that means it may not be there optiv a
single slit like like after single split
the users cluster may still be intact
usually go to use a closet well so so
the split the way split procedure works
you will be guaranteed that you will
never splitter okay so there are normal
questions one can even take this bit
further and sort of try to see can we
actually deal with extremely high
amounts of noise okay so now we are
going to look at a model that's really
what Sanjay was saying so you say much
here and CJ maybe it's possible there's
only one point common in both the
clusters okay so the user is asking you
too much CI and CJ but there's only one
point that's common they can can one do
something in this setting and what we
show is that you can do if the requests
are not adversarial the teacher is not
an adversarial teacher then you can do
something okay safe c star is stable and
at each step amongst the many possible
requests that the teacher can give
suppose the teacher chooses one at
random okay so the teacher is not
adversarial then you can again find find
the optimal clustering using q round so
instead of epsilon 0 plus K it becomes
epsilon 0 plus K squared log in okay so
the teacher is not adversarial then
you can you can handle even even large
amounts of noise okay so just briefly I
want to talk about okay so so we have
this theoretical model we have some some
algorithms do they actually lead to
something useful so here's some very
preliminary results that we ran on on
Mechanical Turk and sort of a domain
that we chose was image segmentation
okay so image segmentation is not the
right maybe the problem to look at
because one already has very good
algorithms for segmentation but it was
convenient for our purposes because it's
very easy to short of show an image to a
user and ask him to point out which
regions look bad and which regions look
good so just for convenience which was
joe's image segmentation and we posed
this as a challenge on Mechanical Turk
so okay so so the process will go on in
round so again the algorithm will
propose some clustering some
segmentation of this image and and the
worker can point to a region and say
this doesn't look good or the worker can
say merge these two regions and so on
and so here are some other segmentations
we get these are the segmentations
obtained in about on average 10 to 11
rounds of interaction okay in about 10
to 11 rounds of interaction sort of get
these are not perfect segmentations but
seem pretty good I mean the point of
these experiments is is to sort of say
that this model at least has the
potential to lead to useful algorithms
okay of course there's a lot more
vehicle work that needs to be presumably
for the initial clustering here you're
starting from the result of
yeah so we start from sort of we take
off the shelf algorithm and we sort of
kuna too so either it can start from
that's a highly over segmented image or
highly under segmented image okay so so
so let me finish the talk so there are a
lot of technical questions that need to
be addressed here so our algorithms not
scalable for instance because it relies
on computing this average linkage tree
which is which is an expensive process
or theorems delete a good bounce but
they still rely on pretty strong
assumptions average stability is not an
assumption that's that's true in
practice okay in other applications
presently at a clustering is not
practical okay so there are some ways we
have some ways to deal with it but it's
don't have the best approaches and again
what what sherry was saying at the
beginning is what if the user is willing
to provide more feedback okay so the
user is may be really helpful he can
pinpoint exactly why I a cluster is bad
can we take advantage of it somehow but
more importantly I think the message of
of this talk is that the interactive
learning can be useful and sometimes
necessary for even tasks which are
traditionally unsupervised and I think
this says it's an area that's not being
studied that much and I think a lot of
exciting work can be done here okay
thank
[Applause]
what this algorithm does is it sort of
gives you an optimal okay in its own
sense so have you performed any studies
comparing this with cross validation
methods for no we haven't I don't really
have a good good answer for that we
haven't done any sort of empirical
studies
you're just getting back in your
examples even the teacher didn't know
like segmentations right how many
clusters right right right right so sort
of when we were running these
experiments we sort of we gave them a
choice of are you happy with this
segmentation or do you want to provide
more feedback and on average about after
ten to eleven rounds people are
reasonably happy so it's not if there
were some instances we are some other
workers were really sort of trying to
fine-tune some of the boundaries and so
so here for instance there will be some
instances where someone is just sort of
really trying to get give you the right
segmentation and then goes on for long
many many rounds but but we give them an
option to say that okay I'm happy and I
want to stop now and most people are
happy okay so did you give the same
picture to multiple people and see the
care of the same result again give the
same picture to multiple people again
similar phenomena most people who are
very happy after a few rounds
in a global sense so that you would be
able to sort of they would be able to
segment our cars and so on but but sort
of the this corner cases like this
pavement here and this part here there's
a lot of that's where there was a lot of
disagreement between some people exactly
right so what you want to do is in sort
of a more crowdsource kind of scenario
you want to give it to multiple people
and then take a take a vote or something
yeah I think this is this is probably a
crazy question it seems like you your
algorithm wants clusters that you know
they are searching is Oscars are happy
with respect with underlying similarity
or distance so do you think like their
have you seen evidence that may be the
the actual users are not happy with the
metric itself and can they detect that
is there a way to tell your average
yeah that's a good question I haven't
thought about it but yeah that's Jesus
might just not be happy with the
matrixes
thanks
[Applause]